ladies and gentlemen jackie
pretty bo
bruised shows the span of halle berry's
range
in more ways than one
and the director is i know halle berry
surreal it's a real
moment a very surreal moment actually
did you even think this moment was
possible for you at this time no and i
think many women don't we don't think
it's possible to sort of take our
destiny into our own hands this way or
in my case answer the call when destiny
knocked because it wasn't what i planned
to do barry did not plan to direct this
film
and at first she wasn't even its leading
lady but she saw the role of jackie
justice through a very different lens it
wasn't even supposed to be for a woman
of color no it was for
a white
young woman in her early twenties you
looked at that i said blake lively had
she had it and i had to wait until she
passed up on it and in the time that i
was waiting i was reimagining what the
story could be should be
why i thought it would be more relevant
if it were a middle-aged woman of color
and not a young woman who's being
offered another chance but
a middle-aged woman who's being offered
a last chance the stakes felt so much
higher when you're at that stage in life
and you're really out of chances and
this is a do or die situation barry
envisioned how the film should be
directed and search for someone she
thought might fit the bill but all roads
led back to her a friend of mine elaine
goldsmith thomas called me and i said
elaine i can't find anybody i don't know
what i'm going to do she said you do it
you're so passionate about it you know
the story inside and out i said elaine i
can't do that this is a large role i
can't then get behind the camera for the
first time and tell the story she goes
that's your problem of course you can i
knew that the story had to have a female
gaze and a female um you know
storytelling
yeah all that stuff had to stay intact i
talked to several women and not that
they weren't great directors but they
didn't see what i saw in my head and
largely because it wasn't on the page
yet but you saw it clearly i saw it
clearly and i thought i was expressing
it clearly to them but the problem was
most of them liked one facet of it
either let's just make it a straight
fight movie
or let's make it a straight drama and
for me it had to be both it had to be
both because women only fight i found
because of the drama
and the trauma in their life so i didn't
think i could tell an authentic fight
story without understanding why this
woman was fighting why she would get in
the ring and participate in a blood
sport he cleaned yourself all right
so i couldn't separate the two she
couldn't separate the actress from the
actual fighter either the big blow left
berry with two broken ribs two days into
shooting this scene
i knew i'd broken something i had broken
three ribs on the movie before john wick
so you knew the feeling you know what it
felt like but i also knew in that moment
because on john wick when i told them
something was hurt they shut down for
eight weeks but that was john wick they
could absorb a big shutdown like that
this little indie movie that i had to
piece together and find the financing
for
that which i had one day and didn't have
the next day i knew we couldn't absorb a
shutdown i would lose my money i would
probably lose valentina and i would
never
get back to this so barry says she
fought through the pain and bruise
became the number one movie on netflix
the week of its release the streaming
giant mark berry's directorial debut
with a special message i love this
hallie directed by halle berry loves
saying that
i love seeing that so when you see it
what do you what are you thinking
i'm looks like your eyes are watering up
a little bit well that's not hard for me
gail you know me no it means everything
you know i i never thought
that would be me you know i never
dared dream that big dream so now that
you've got the directing down what's
next on your list
i don't know i'm just stuck in this
moment right now
you know
basking in this because life hasn't you
know there's valleys and peaks and i'm
on a peak right now
on your birthday this past year on
instagram you said in the midst of the
storm
i've managed to create happiness find
more peace feel more free than ever how
have you been able to do that
because you've been through a lot hallie
i know i think finally
all the pieces are coming together yeah
i've got my children they're healthy
they're happy finally
all of that domestic stuff is working
itself out yeah good um i just directed
my first movie i'm doing my career on my
terms i feel great about that that i'm
still here after 30 years and you have
love in your life i have love in my life
which i have to say gives me hope
it should how did you know that van hunt
was the one for you and i saw his name
in the credits of this movie i know he
yeah he wrote uh and produced automatic
woman yes
you know how i knew gail for the first
time
i approached a relationship in a way i
never had before what is that how we
didn't meet each other face to face for
three months
for the first three months all we did
was talk and write letters and emails to
each other that was it no face timing
even just talking on the phone
writing letters and emailing and i
realized for the first time
i liked the person
i was gonna have a relationship with
you're known you know there's there's no
question about your beauty i love the
statistics of you were named one of the
most beautiful women of the century
you were named one of people magazines
most beautiful women of all time all of
the accolades go to halle berry for as
long as i can remember and i've heard
you say that beauty can be a blessing
and a curse i get the blessing part tell
me how it's been accursed for you and
how you navigate that
what is a hard thing to say because most
people are like oh sorry for you haley
no no no i don't know but i don't see it
like that but it's been a box that
has attempted to define me and limit me
and when i tell you all i've longed for
gail is for someone to say something to
me other than you're beautiful you're so
pretty i want to hear you're talented
you're a great mother i love what you
did which is one of the reasons facing
this directorial challenge became
something that i needed like the air to
breathe i thought finally can i prove
that i'm more than this shell that i'm
walking around in that i had nothing to
do with i came here this way yeah i want
credit for something that i did yeah you
know that i created that i'm responsible
for yeah and so yeah that has felt like
a curse because it's
i have felt locked and limited by it and
diminished by it let me finally be more
than that in life you are so much so
more than that in life halle berry your
real name is maria halle berry but it's
so nice to see when your personal and
your professional life lines up yeah at
the same time and you're both really
happy and she got a little emotional at
the end because i think she has felt
that she's had to prove herself she has
a struggle she by the way she loves
boxing but she says that i'm a fighter
i've had to fight my whole life and i
will continue to fight and she's in such
a good place and getting such accolades
for this movie and her directorial debut
it's just good to see her so happy it
said a lot when you were asking about
the future and she said no no no gail
this moment right now
i want to stay here
speaking of her being a fighter she
fought to prove she was much more than a
pretty face yes she has done that give
her flowers yes the most versatile
talents in the business but that said
she is a pretty face her skin is like
butterscotch i want to kick a spoon
oh god you're so
shout out gorgeous hollywood